CBS is hit Sitcom.
The Big Bang theory delights in hooking fun and it's male characters.
Were there fanboy obsessions with comic books,
video games,
and
often the punch lines aren't really jokes per se.
Instead,
laughs are derived by simply referencing something that sounds vaguely nerdy.
Did you shut the TV off in the middle of the classic deep space?
Nine Star Trek,
the original series trouble with tribbles crossover.
Yeah.
I suspect this is one of the reasons why so many people involved in Geek
subcultures tend to dislike the show so much.
It's essentially one long joke at their expense,
but I'd argue there's something more pernicious going on just under the surface,
so that's cool.
If I cry a little,
yeah,
I probably wouldn't.
Yeah.
Beyond its general mocking of Geekdom,
the show is relentless in making fun of it's male characters for not living up
to traditional expectations of manhood.
On the surface.
It might seem like these nerdy nice guys represent a welcome alternative to the
Macho archetypes that we've all come to expect from Hollywood,
but on closer inspection we find that despite their status as nerdy outsiders,
these guys are still complicit in many of the most destructive aspects of toxic
masculinity.
Yes,
but our society has undergone a paradigm shift in the information age.
Sheldon,
you and I are the Alpha males.
We shouldn't have to back down.
I'm going to assert my dominance face to face in my previous video essay about
the adorkable misogynists trope.
I discussed the creepy entitled and often sexist ways in which these geeky guys
treat women
and then we get them up to about a 0.15 blood alcohol level and tell them we're
millionaires.
But I think it's also worth examining how they treat each other.
The first thing we need is a theme.
I'm thinking to another century.
I'm thinking you need a testosterone patch and by extension how the show's
writers end up reinforcing a whole bunch of regressive ideas about what it means
to be a real man.
Beer wings,
sliders,
we can watch the football game.
I even painted my stomach.
There's a running gag on this show about how Leonard doesn't understand sports
or other activities that are stereotypically associated with men.
Go Sports.
Wow.
It gets you in the mood for baseball.
I didn't want to look ridiculous.
Yes.
Are you people watching this?
This is amazing.
Or what sweetie?
That's a highlight from 98 championship game.
Not Know that
the joke relies on the assumption that all men are supposed to like sports and
therefore it's inherently funny and absurd if a guy does it.
Now sitcoms are of course supposed to be funny,
but as with all comedy,
it's important to ask who are we meant to laugh with and who are we meant to
laugh at?
Okay.
Notice the laughter in this scene stems almost entirely from seeing Howard
wearing an apron.
What's with the gloves?
They complete my ensemble.
What do you want?
The humor relies on the sexist idea that domestic tasks like cooking and
cleaning our women's work and therefore Howard's masculinity is somehow
diminished by being forced to clean the house.
This reductive mix of sexism and emasculation is really at the heart of the
show's comedic formulas.
When I failed to open this jar and you succeed,
it will establish you as the Alpha male.
I'm not strong enough,
Leonard.
You'll have to do it.
Go ahead.
It's pre loosened.
Notice that these jokes aren't designed to challenge or subvert the limiting and
often toxic ideas about what it means to be a real man.
No,
no,
no.
Instead,
the punchlines reinforced this notion that guys who aren't physically strong,
tough,
or athletic are unmanly enough cardio for me,
stretch out
and therefore worthy of routines.
Hold on.
It
doesn't make sense.
In order to move forward in this discussion,
we're going to have to get academic just for a minute and very quickly define a
couple terms.
Those are hegemonic masculinity and hypermasculinity head Germantic.
Masculinity is a term that's used to describe the socially constructed ideal of
manhood.
It's characterized by things like physical strength,
aggression,
domination,
suppression of emotions and heterosexuality.
The ideal varies somewhat based on factors like geography,
but here I'm concerned with white western manhood has shaped by Hollywood for
obvious examples.
Think of Conan the barbarian James Bond or captain America.
All the guys on the Big Bang theory are depicted as embodying the exact opposite
of that hedge mnemonic ideal and that man,
okay,
so much so that simply seeing them dress up as their favorite superhero is in
and of itself a punchline.
I mean,
the important thing to understand about this manhood ideal is that it's a
fiction.
It only really exists in the cultural imagination,
which means that men can never actually achieve it.
However,
it's still a standard against which men are held and compared.
The social expectations and pressures on men to try to achieve some version of
it is real has is the social status either lost or gained based on a man's
perceived proximity.
Okay.
Did that ideal?
The term hyper masculinity is a little different.
It refers to the set of attitudes and behaviors associated with the pursuit of
that hegemonic idea.
Hypermasculinity includes things like aggressive competition,
sexual conquest and destructive or risk taking behaviors like fighting,
reckless driving or heavy drinking.
Hyper masculinity is also obsessively antifeminist.
Now keep that in mind because it's going to be important a little later.
Hyper masculine behaviors are how men are taught to perform their manhood to
prove that they are closer to that fictional ideal.
Then the other men around them before geeks on the Big Bang theory are shown
constantly attempting to perform some version of hypermasculinity.
Nope.
Prepare yourself for what may come.
Oh Shelton,
did you really think we're going to fight?
They're spectacular failures in their quest to prove their manhood.
Then provides the ironic hook behind much of the shows comedy.
I see this one time instead of wimping out,
let's be bad ass is okay.
I'd be a bad ass,
but only if your biggest swear to be one too.
Okay.
Now you'd think a bunch of Geeks who are regularly derided for being unmanly
would be supportive of each other's insecurities and although there are fleeting
moments of compassion between the four friends,
they spend much of their time marking and humiliating each other for not living
up to the manhood deal.
I see you decided to get with pathetic and frightening.
It's one of his best moves.
Having female problems.
If you're cranky and retaining water.
I have a theory.
Yeah.
Did
you talk to her about this?
Oh Geez.
Why do you girls always want to talk about things?
This may seem a little counterintuitive.
Why would nerds who are bullied for not acting manly enough then turn around and
replicate that same behavior within their own circles?
Well,
it's because one of the ways men learn to perform manhood shall pass is by
exerting power over others.
Remember when I said that one of the characteristics of hyper masculinity was an
obsession with being anti feminine.
A girl's night off.
I'm up,
I'm up for an evening talking about rainbows,
Unicorns and menstrual cramps.
Time and again,
we see the men on the show,
demeaning women and expressing the casual disdain for anything considered girl
stuff.
Sex in the city.
Yikes.
Hey,
I happen to love this movie.
Let me swatch it.
Maybe all our periods will synchronize.
Anti Feminine Attitudes are also connected to the ways that men police each
other's presentation of manhood.
Because of your lactose intolerance,
you switched over to soy milk.
Soy contains estrogen mimicking compounds.
I think your morning cocoa puffs are turning you into a hysterical woman.
Just so we're clear.
When men insult and belittle other men by calling them women,
that is an extension of misogyny.
Yeah,
you're controlling.
You're irritated.
There you go again,
Nag,
Nag.
You're only proving my point.
Little Lady.
Nowhere is this dynamic as clear as in the show's treatment of Raj Edwards only
pushing you away because he loves you.
Got Everything we need for the big game.
Low Fat Turkey Jerky,
low carb bill hundred calorie snack.
Okay.
Pick up the y chromosome while you were there.
You might be short one.
I won't be making fun of you or the things you like or the fact that you just
wanna have fun
practically every episode over 10 seasons.
The other characters on the show make fun of Raj for acting too much.
Like a woman,
wasn't a Pajama Party.
He was just a couple of Bros hanging out,
giggling,
eating cookie dough and watching princess bride.
Okay,
please stop talking.
As you might expect,
the jokes targeting Raj for not being manly enough are steeped in a thick layer
of homophobia.
Wow.
And that's not even the best part.
See,
I have one too.
Check it out.
You can make yours and we can have little sword fights whenever we want.
The humor consistently codes.
Raj has more a feminine behaviors and interests as gay and that's always the
punchline.
May I have a crossover with the little umbrella piece?
We may not.
Why I'm not sitting here with a guy drinking a grasshopper with that little
umbrella.
Bye.
I love a chocolate Martini.
Again,
Raj is the only one of the four guys who after 230 episodes still doesn't have a
steady girlfriend.
Do you have any idea what it's like to be the only one without a good friend?
Even if I get one someday I sit with the guy who got a gun after Sheldon Cooper.
All the others have had their longterm partners join the main cast.
I don't think it's a coincidence that the character most ridiculed for being the
most unmanly in a group of men,
specifically coded to be unmanly is also the only man of color on the show and
as such,
Raj fits neatly into Hollywood's long running tradition.
Of mocking and diminishing the sexuality of Asian men
at times.
Raj seems comfortable with is softer nor a feminine version of it.
Manhood,
Bridget Jones' diary like God,
I'm good,
I got 50 but the show and the other male characters are not and they let Raj and
us as the audience know that there's something wrong with him for not being
manly enough every chance they get what's up,
not his testosterone levels.
Excuse me.
I happened to be very comfortable with my masculinity and how is that possible
in her 1995 book,
masculinities are w Connell lays out the theory that there's not just one form
of masculinity but rather many different forms of manhood that all exist within
a hierarchy.
The white heterosexual,
hyper masculine ideal is at the top of that hierarchy and then all other forms
of masculinity are made subordinate to it.
Forms of manhood that are in any way associated with homosexuality or femininity
are pushed further down on the hierarchy when you,
I slapped him,
take it in like
this hierarchical structure then creates a social system wherein men are
encouraged to compete with other men for status and dominance even within their
own peer groups and subcultures.
You want some more?
This is why even men who are bullied for not meeting the hyper masculine ideal
often feel the only way they can be seen as real men
is by diminishing someone else.
I am.
She bought destroyed.
I wouldn't have the woman.
I'm warning you.
I was judo champion at bath.
The relationship dynamics between Leonard is Sheldon Howard and Raj provides us
with a microcosm of how this hierarchy of masculinities works.
Good.
I'm glad you finally got a girlfriend but you to do all that lovey dovey stuff
in front of those of us who don't actually,
he might have to.
There's an economic concept and then as a positional good in which an object is
only valued by the possessor because it's not possessed by others.
It's not true.
My happiness is not dependent on my best friend being miserable and alone.
Thank you.
Although I'd be lying if I said it wasn't a little bit of a perk.
Practically every aspect of their friendship from the personal to the
professional revolves around competition.
Once you do that,
to send a message,
she is not for you.
Back off Sheldon,
what if she could not stop hitting on my lady?
You will feel the full extent of my ras it relax.
I am not interested in your girlfriend.
You don't want to mess with me.
I am crazy.
Do it.
In fact,
their entire lives are defined by a never ending game of oneupmanship.
Don't just stand there.
Take your breaths out on the Big Bang theory.
Just like in the real world,
women are often leveraged as symbols of status within groups of male friends
to show people when they don't believe me,
the show consistently frames manhood as something that's either reaffirmed or
diminished by the ability of the guys to score with women
at work.
Leave it alone.
That's my girlfriend.
Sorry.
We just had sex with me at work.
How'd you swing that?
Two women at the same time.
Nice job play.
Whenever any one of the four nerds doesn't have a girlfriend,
the others will ridicule him for it.
Knock,
knock,
who's there?
I have a girlfriend and you don't.
I have a functioning and satisfying relationship with a female.
You have none under the narrow constraints of hyper masculinity.
The only thing worse than being unable to acquire a woman is being controlled by
one.
I downloaded an APP that might be helpful in this situation.
Now the women on the show occasionally join in with the ridicule for another
beer.
I'm good.
No thank you girls.
But the vast majority of the putdowns of nerdy men don't come from women.
They come from other names.
Please.
I am trying to figure out a way to intellectually emasculate a dear friend of
mine.
Hey,
why do you decide is better in bed?
Begot Zach.
Oh,
wheezy little lantern.
Ah,
there is an unfortunate tendency in our culture to try to pin the blame for
men's emasculation on women,
but most of the time the perpetrators are men.
We're participating in this competition for dominance
and in so doing,
they become complicit in the very structures that harm and exclude them.
You know,
for a group of guys who claim they spent most of their lives being bullied,
you can be real jerks.
Shame on all of you.
All this competitive and anti antifeminist behavior is framed by the show as
harmless,
as good natured,
fun as normal and natural and inevitable for men.
But the reality is that the social pressures that society places on men to
engage in this hyper masculine competition is anything but harmless.
It can be dangerous for men and for those around them,
both in terms of physical health and emotional wellbeing.
It makes it difficult,
if not impossible for straight men to be vulnerable and caring with others,
which in turn makes it very hard to build close,
supportive friendships with women and with other men.
It was quite a gesture on your part,
shown yourself to be the bigger man.
Thank you.
Which I find totally unacceptable.
I must be the bigger man.
Okay.
Unlike Leonard Sheldon,
Howard and Raj,
who are locked into a perpetual competition by their writers,
men in the real world have a choice.
We can choose to reject the battle for dominance and instead embrace empathetic
and supportive forms of manhood.
Thanks so much for watching.
If you like these long form video essay is about the intersections of
entertainment and masculinity,
then please consider going over to Patrion and helping to fund this project.
There's also a link to paypal in the description below.
I will see you all again next month with another video essay.